oh i'm back everyone hooray
whenever i go on holiday or take a break
from making videos i always come back
like
how do i how do i make videos i don't
know but i think this is interesting
so maybe you guys will think this is
interesting as well and that is
ufo footage videos yeah
[Music]
do you think aliens are real no
judgement you can answer
oh that's your opinion
so there's some footage from i think
that now is leaked i haven't really
looked into it too much
but i think the government is going to
release the same footage but this
is elite ufo footage newly released
footage taken aboard a u.s
navy ship showing what appears to be
ufos flying off the coast of california
yeah that's right
yeah help me
it's always america isn't it why does no
one else get a bunch of ufo footage
and why is the camera quality worse than
mine for once i mean i'll take it i look
good
i look nice and crisp compared to that
what the [ __ ]
joins us live from montrose with what
people are saying about
nice videos i i love this when when news
anchors
they're commenting on a footage that's
like years old but uh
i'm outside we're capturing this live
where ufos are
outside
[Laughter]
it's so good turns out to be true this
is the biggest story of our lifetime
chelsea
i mean it's huge right alex this is part
of a national conversation right now
ahead of that report that we're expected
to get next month now the person who
leaked
the biggest story of our lifetime that's
why everyone is talking about it
obviously this is what news agencies do
they want to create a story
so they hype it up alien's real but if
you look closely on the video
it's not an alien ufo i'm gonna explain
what this is
it's a giant bee i know
it's shocking open your eyes giant b
huge look at the size of that thing all
right let's take a look at the footage
in this recently leaked video taken by
the us navy a mysterious sphere appears
to hover off the san diego coast before
disappearing
into the ocean whoa
it's cool right it just disappears it
moves from left to right
really quickly i like it however
i don't know why i took it upon myself
to do this because i'm not qualified but
i'm gonna explain what happened here
first of all you see the object moving
from left to right really quickly
which is a puzzling way of an object to
travel
however it's not the object that is
moving
it's the camera that is moving and you
can see this
if you look at at the waves as a
reference
because the waves are moving not the
object footage obtained by filmmaker
do you see that look at the waves
instead of the object by filmmaker jeri
the camera is rotating to the object the
object isn't swaying back and forth does
that make sense
the obtained by look at that jeremy now
to explain
why it looks like it's splashed the way
these infrared cameras work is that
black means heat so they're not
necessarily looking at a round object
they're looking at a round source of
heat
really which could be solid you know
let's say
it's a bird then yeah it could look like
this i think
but most likely if you look at the
splash and after a few minutes
the splash perfume you can see it blings
out
and it's not like half the thing
disappears first
and then it's all gone it's rather the
whole thing is gone it kind of blinks
for a second look at it again
i don't know why i think this is so fun
and after a few minutes there you go
and there's a fun way to explain this
again if you
imagine a source of heat like say
a light some jet i don't know
this will show us as black on a as a
black round object on an infrared camera
right
now if i try to cover it even though
i'm technically covering uh where the
light is coming from
you still see half of it even though i
covered halfway but not until i covered
all of it
it disappears like you can see it in
front of the
the book that i'm using to cover does
that make sense
as opposed to if i try and cover a full
object
you see half object it's not solid
it's a source of light oh kind of cool
yeah it doesn't splash it just gets out
of
either past the horizon or out of range
i don't know that doesn't mean we know
what it is
all right alien could still reel okay
but i'm just saying
it's not as interesting as the footage
it may seem you know this object that
grew and it disappears and splash but it
that's not what really is happening uh
the other footage is also really cool i
love this
navy destroyer this was taken me is that
all they show
it looks like giant triangle upside down
pyramid ufo hovering above a navy
destroyer
there you go alien doritos i knew it
above a navy destroyer
everyone ganks until giant tic tac dives
into the ocean
i'm longer for the day when a ufo video
isn't recorded with the potato
i mean that's why because we're using
all this technology to really just film
ourselves
so this footage is taken from uh the
navy
and they are funny enough looking at an
object that is
blinking in the exact same way as a
typical
boeing aircraft you know they have the
the blinking lights
and it's also captured underneath the
flight route
of these aircrafts from uh hawaii to
california
but it could be a giant triangle alien
as well
i'm just saying either way is possible
now what the reason why it looks like a
triangle destroyer
is because if you look at an object
really far away
uh that's out of focus you've probably
seen this in movies right when they have
all this nice footage and the lights
that are really far away look huge right
here
look at these giant aliens it's the same
principle
and and the way you get a triangle one
is if you have
a triangular lens cap kind of like this
so if it's not closed a lot of lens caps
close this way and if it's not open
the entire way you get this sort of
effect
which is cool so let's say you're
looking at an aircraft
with an infra or night vision camera
where the lens cap that isn't closed
fully
it will look like a giant illuminati
alien spaceship this is part of a much
larger series of events that we're going
to be learning about
all right calm down calm down i think
it's
it's fun right the idea of believing in
aliens and you get this really cool
footage
and i hate to i'm not here to step on
anyone's dreams and hopes okay i want to
die from aliens too
that would be epic but what they always
do
especially news agents are news media
whatever when they have new footage that
comes out that is false
as evidence of the aliens or ufo they
never say it really but
it's in it's in implied they always back
it up with these old footage
that people have debugged so there's new
uh false footage
as proof of aliens comes up it's uh
gets proved as real by more fake
older ones so it becomes a narrative
kind of like when we
get colonoscopy online oh look at all
this we don't have this solid evidence
but we have all this other
bad evidence i don't know why i slunk
that in there but it's kind of the same
principle
so they have this footage which came out
three years ago i think
and i remember seeing this i thought it
was really puzzling because it looks
amazing
he says one of the biggest problems is
the stigma that comes with talking about
ufos
something oh god damn there and i'll
show it hold up i know what it's called
here's the footage
[Laughter]
so the story about this is what really
makes it cool because
the air pilots uh didn't know what
exactly they were looking at either and
they came out this new york times
article and the footage was first leaked
and people weren't sure about the
footage i'm like oh it's fake it's some
stupid [ __ ]
but then the government released that uh
the united states government released
the footage and said no it's real
here's uh here's the footage
so it looks like this object is
traveling
really fast it looks really cool but in
reality
the way we're seeing this footage is
from a fighter jet
of some sort that's obviously moving
really fast and
we have the background of the ocean okay
let's imagine you you are moving really
fast all right
follow me here okay and let's say you're
looking at this microphone
if you are moving really fast okay my
hand is the background it's the
represents the waves and my this is you
this is funny okay the object itself
doesn't have to move
if you really zoomed in on it for it to
appear like it's moving
does that make sense okay this is good
if you're looking at
an object from point a and then you move
to point b with a distant background
your background will be different
making it appear like the object is
moving really fast when in reality
you're just looking at a different
background
so the viewpoint being a fighter jet
moving really fast the object itself
doesn't have to move fat
at all or fast for it to appear like it
is moving fast
here's a from i am goddard oh it's from
uh
mcquest he does a really good debunking
videos
you can see us this ball is not moving
but it looks like it's moving
really fast because it's really zoomed
in and the camera itself is moving
[Music]
this is funny because we're tricking
ourselves in these scenarios
it could be a bird it could be a weather
balloon i don't know
but the footage itself doesn't prove i
mean it doesn't prove anything
not everyone is convinced that ufos
exists
others say we can't be alone i think
they're out there
it would be ludicrous to think that
we're the only sentient beings
in this entire universe this is a
he has a point there though i mean i i
can totally say i believe that
there could be life in the universe if
you think of the absolute
vast scope of the universe and uh human
existence
being so improbable but still uh
occurring
it'd be kind of native to think that we
are the only ones alone but there's a
narrative that
alien spacecraft are flying around to
monitor
us for whatever reason is with this
footage to back it up it's just kind of
ludicrous
life out there that we don't know about
yet now uh this is all some of the video
that's now being reviewed by a
government ufo research group alex and
christine that does exist
uh congress has actually requested a
report on ufos
yes of course the government is going to
have unidentified foreign object
department that is not weird at all that
makes perfect
sense but people associate ufo with
aliens so it's like whoa
the government looks at aliens no that's
not it at all
there's obviously more footage but i
think that kind of
those are the ones i thought that were
cool there's a lot of people believing
it's real
in the comments so i don't know what
people are going to think of this video
but if you enjoyed i thought it was
interesting
smash like subscribe backward videos
yet again check out the new merch by the
way 110 million club and i'll see you
guys tomorrow
[Music]
brofist
and you can't go to the zoo need to go
to the [ __ ] loop
i got something
even ones that i can't see just download
it for free
for free download
i got something for you
[Applause]
you